FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN TEXAS TODAY
FOR A FIRSTHAND LOOK AT WHAT HE
CALLS THE HUMANITARIAN AND
SECURITY CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
TWO DAYS AFTER A MAJOR
OVAL OFFICE ADDRESS AND IN DAY
20 OF THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
WHICH REMAINS AT A STALEMATE.
BEFORE HE LEFT, THE PRESIDENT
VOWED NOT TO CAVE ON HIS DESIRED
BORDER ALL WITH MEXICO INSTEAD
HE HAS THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
DECLARE EMERGENCY IF HE CAN'T RA
DECLARE EMERGENCY IF HE CAN'T RH
DEAL WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
>> I HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
I HAVEN'T DONE IT YET.
I MAY DO IT.
IF THIS DOESN'T WORK OUT,
PROBABLY I WILL DO IT.
I WOULD ALMOST SAY DEFINITELY.
IF WE DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT.
>> Dana: WHILE ON THE GROUND
IN McALLEN, TEXAS, THE
PRESIDENT DOUBLED DOWN ON HIS
CLAIM THAT MEXICO WILL BE
PLAYING FOR THE -- PAYING FOR
THE WALL.
>> DO YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
WRITE A CHECK?
NO.
THEY ARE PAYING FOR THE WALL AND
A GREAT TRADE DEAL.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR WILL BE MADE NOW AS
OPPOSED TO NAFTA WHICH WAS A
DISASTER.
>> Dana: TRUMP LET A BORDER
PATROL AGENT EXPLAINED THE NEED
FOR A WALL.
>> YESTERDAY WE ARE PRINTED 133
PEOPLE FROM COUNTRIES OTHER THAN
CENTRAL AMERICA AND MEXICO.
THAT INCLUDES INDIA, PAKISTAN,
CHINA, ROMANIA, NECK ARAGUA.
ON AND ON.
I KNOW WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
FAMILY UNIT.
THAT MAKES UP ABOUT TYPICALLY
ABOUT 60, 70%.
WE'VE SEEN A CHANGE WITHOUT
NUMBER IS LESS THEN 50% OF THE
APPREHENSIONS WE MAKE IN SOUTH
TEXAS.
WE HAVE 55 MILES IN THE SECTOR.
WE STARTED THE JOB IN 2006.
WE NEED TO FINISH THE JOB.
WE NEED THE TECHNOLOGY AND
RESOURCES.
WE NEED THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO CONTROL THIS BORDER.
>> Dana: GREG, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
BORDER PATROL AGENT, YOU'VE BEEN
RECOMMENDING THIS.
LET THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
SPEAK.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Greg: IS NOT JUST THE
AGENTS.
IT'S ALSO ENGINEERS.
THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION
REQUIRES A LOT OF NUANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU INJECT
POLITICS INTO ANYTHING, THE
FIRST THING THAT DISAPPEARS IS
NUANCE AND COMPROMISE.
POLITICS IS THE CARBON MONOXIDE
OF THINKING.
IT'S ODORLESS, COLORLESS AND
WHEN IT ENTERS THE ROOM, ALL
IDEAS DIE.
WHAT THEY DO, NUANCE AND
COMPROMISE DRIVES ME CRAZY.
IT'S REPLACED WITH THE PRISON OF
TWO IDEAS.
EVEN THOUGH CHUCK AGREES WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND HAS AGREED WITH
HIM, HE HAS TO GO TO HIS
RESPECTIVE PRISON.
HE HAS TO GO TO THAT OTHER
PERSON'S HEALTH.
HE CAN'T COME OUT.
EVEN THOUGH HE AGREES WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
SO EVERYBODY HAS TO CHOOSE THEIR
SIDE AND THEY HAVE TO LIVE IN
THEIR OWN PRISONS AND EVERY DAY
THIS GOES ON AND CREATES MORE
AND MORE LIBERTARIANS OR PEOPLE
WHO ARE SO DISGUSTED BY
POLITICS, THEY ARE FORCED TO
TALK TO THEIR FAMILY INSTEAD
WHICH IS GOOD.
THE REAL WINNER AT THE BORDER
VISIT, TED CRUZ'S BEARD.
HE WENT FROM TED CRUZ TO CRUISE
MISSILE.
I LOOK AT THAT AND GO I'M NOT
MESSING WITH THAT GUY.
IF HE HAD GROWN THAT BEARDEN
2015, HE MIGHT BE PRESIDENT OR
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T NEED THE
WALL.
WE JUST HAVEN'T TED CRUZ
STANDING THERE.
IN THE JACKET, JUST SCARE THEM
AWAY.
>> Dana: HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT
ABOUT GROWING A BEARD?
>> I HAVE TRIED.
I GROW BEARD BUT IT STOPS AROUND
THE CHAIN.
I HAVE LIKE MARTIN        MUTTOH
I HAVE LIKE MARTIN        MUTTOP
I HAVE LIKE MARTIN        MUTTO.
IS THAT WHAT THEY ARE CALLED?
THEN I GET FOOD IN IT WHICH IS
GREAT.
>> Jesse: THIS IS TWO WEEKS I
HAVEN'T SHAVED.
I AM A BABY.
>> Juan: I CAN GROW BEARD.
I HAD A BEARD OVER VACATION.
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT THOSE
TERRORISTS CROSSING THE BORDER
WHEN I SAW THE GUY STANDING
BEHIND THE PRESIDENT AND THEN I
REALIZED IT WAS TED CRUZ TRYING
TO MAKE UP FOR NOT A BORDER WALL
BUT THE ABSENCE OF A CHIN.
>> Dana: OH, JUAN.
>> Juan: WHAT DID YOU SAY,
CRUISE MISSILE?
"THE FIVE" LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE THIS
MORNING THAT A COUPLE DEMOCRATIC
FRESHMAN WHO JUST WON, DEMOCRATS
WOULD BE REPUBLICANS IN CLOSE
RACES BUT THEY BEAT THEM FAIR
AND SQUARE.
NOW THEY ARE STARTING TO SAY WE
ARE FOR BORDER SECURITY AND THIS
IS NOT NECESSARILY GOOD THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE IN A POSITION OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO BUILD ANY
COALITIONS OR GET ANYTHING DONE
IF THIS IS OUR FIRST ATTEMPT OUT
OF THE GATE.
DO YOU THINK THERE CRACKS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC OPPOSITION TO GETTING
THE MONEY FOR THE WALL?
>> Jesse: I THINK THE CRACKS
ARE COMING FROM THE FOLKS
BURNING UP THE PHONE LINES.
THAT'S WHAT POLITICIANS RESPOND
TO, LETTERS AND PHONE CALLS.
IF YOU START CALLING AND
CLOGGING OF THE PHONE LINES,
THEY THINK THEIR CONSTITUENTS
ARE ANGRY AND THEY WANT BORDER
SECURITY AND THEY WILL RESPOND.
THAT'S THE BEST PART OF
DEMOCRACY.
PICK UP THE PHONE AND TELL THESE
GUYS WHAT TO DO.
THEY WORK FOR THE PEOPLE, NOT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
YOU CAN SEE THE NEEDLE MOVING A
LITTLE BIT.
I HONESTLY THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME TRUMP HAS USED THE
TRADITIONAL PRESIDENTIAL SQUEEZE
PLAY ON AN ISSUE.
YOU DO THE OVAL OFFICE ADDRESS.
YOU DO THE PHOTO OFF WITH THE
WHITE HAT.
YOU DO THE SOCIAL MEDIA, ASKED
PEOPLE TO CALL THEIR
CONGRESSMAN.
MAYBE HAVE A COUPLE RALLIES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
TAKE A TRIP TO THE BORDER AND
THEN YOU THREATEN SOMETHING IN
RIGHT NOW IT COULD BE WORKING.
WITH THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
DO IS THEY ARE TRYING TO PROLONG
THIS SO PAYCHECKS ARE PAID, ONE
WEEK, THAT FLICKS NEW PAIN INTO
THE CONVERSATION.
THAT MAY AFFECT THE DYNAMIC A
LITTLE BIT.
IF THEY CAN TIME THE PAYCHECK
MISS A COUPLE MORE WEEKS, EVEN
TIME IT WITH THE MUELLER REPORT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT DOUBLE
WHAMMY RIGHT THERE?
>> Dana: YEAH, I DON'T -- I
STILL THINK --
>> Jesse: YOU SAID HE WAS
WRAPPING UP.
>> Dana: WHAT, WHO WAS
WRAPPING UP?
>> Jesse: MUELLER.
>> Dana: I KEEP SAYING THAT.
THIS IS MY THEORY.
NO ONE HAS TOLD ME THIS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, JEDEDIAH,
TOMORROW IS GOING TO USURP THE
DEMOCRATS THAT HE WILL DECLARE
THIS NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND BE
ABLE TO SAY I END OF THE
SHUTDOWN.
DEMOCRATS WOULDN'T DO IT.
I HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO THIS
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THERE IS CONTROVERSY AROUND IT
BUT THAT HE WILL BE ABLE TO SAY
I'M ENDING THE SHUTDOWN.
I APPROVED THE NEED FOR THE
BORDER FENCE.
>> Jedidiah: THEN HE WILL GET
CREDIT FOR ENDING THE SHUTDOWN
BUT YOU WILL HAVE EVERYONE
COMING AFTER HIM.
OH, YOU ACTED UNILATERALLY.
YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT CONGRESS.
YOU DIDN'T DO THIS THE RIGHT
WAY.
I REALLY THINK IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE FOR HIM TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, EVEN THOUGH
I DO THINK HE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DO IT IN THIS CASE.
>> Dana: DON'T YOU THINK HE'S
MARCHING HIS WAY UP?
>> Jedidiah: ABSOLUTELY.
HE KEEPS SAYING I AM WITHIN MY
RIGHT TO DO IT AND IF DEMOCRATS
DON'T HELP, GOING TO HAVE TO DO
IT.
BUT TO ANSWER A QUESTION BEFORE,
I THINK A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ARE
COMING FORWARD AND SAYING TO
PEOPLE, OTHER DEMOCRATS, THIS IS
ONE-TENTH OF 1% OF THE BUDGET WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO BE ON
RECORD AS NOT WANTING TO GIVE
$5.6 BILLION FOR THE BORDER WHEN
WE ARE ASKING FOR A $27 BILLION
IN FOREIGN AID?
THIS IS NOT A GOOD POSITION TO
BE IN.
IT'S A FRACTION.
THESE ARE THE VERY DEMOCRATS WHO
HAVE BEEN ON RECORD, AS WE SAID,
COMING FORTH IN FAVOR BORDER
SECURITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POLLING
AROUND THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THEY WANT THE BORDER SECURE.
THEY MAY NOT WANT THE WALL
BECAUSE IT'S TIED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NOW THEY
ASSOCIATE IT WITH HIM BUT THEY
WANT BORDER SECURITY.
I THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT THIS AND FRANKLY
IF THEY'RE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE SHUTDOWN, I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE A BIG --
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
BEING HELD RESPONSIBLE.
>> Juan: THE POLLS ARE PRETTY
CLEAR.
THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER" TODAY
SAID IT LOOKS LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE TAKEN
THEMSELVES HOSTAGE AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW YOU CAN GET YOUR TAX
REFUNDS, FOOD STAMPS DELAYED.
THEY ARE TRYING TO AMELIORATE
THE DAMAGE THAT COMES FROM A 20
DAY SHUTDOWN.
THE DIFFICULTY FOR REPUBLICANS,
ESPECIALLY IN STATES LIKE
COLORADO, CORY GARDNER.
OR EVEN LISA MURKOWSKI IN
ALASKA, EITHER WITH HISPANIC
POPULATION SIGNIFICANT OR A LOT
OF FEDERAL WORKERS, THEY FEEL
THIS IS GOING TO HURT THEM WITH
VOTERS.
THEY ARE STARTING TO HEAR FROM
THEIR CONSTITUENTS THIS ISN'T
SUCH A GREAT DEAL.
TO GO TO A JEDEDIAH WAS TALKING
ABOUT, I THINK THE NEWS OF TODAY
WAS THAT HE DIDN'T DECLARE THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
I THINK PART OF THAT IS
REPUBLICANS, MAYBE I SHOULDN'T
SAY REPUBLICANS.
I SHOULD SAY CONSERVATIVES.
REMEMBER HOW STRONGLY
CONSERVATIVES CRITICIZED
PRESIDENTS IN THE PAST FOR
ACTING IN A TYRANNICAL OR
DESPOTIC WAY AND SAYING I AM
GOING AROUND CONGRESS.
NEVER ONCE IN AMERICAN HISTORY
HAS AN EMERGENCY BEEN DECLARED
WHEN THE PRESIDENT COULD NOT GET
FUNDING FOR AN ISSUE THROUGH THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
AND WENT AROUND THE CONGRESS.
THAT'S NOT IN KEEPING WITH OUR
CONSTITUTION.
I THINK A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES
HAVE REAL PROBLEMS WITH THIS.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THE NEWS
OF THE DAY WAS THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE FROM 140 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES OR 40 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES BESIDES
CENTRAL AMERICA THAT WERE TRYING
TO CROSS THE BORDER THAT THEY
APPREHENDED.
IT'S LIKE A UNITED NATIONS
MIGRATION INTO THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND THE BORDER PATROL
SAID PAKISTAN, INDIA, ROMANIA.
PEOPLE FROM ROMANIA, JUAN.
THEY ARE COMING.
YOU CAN'T CALL THE PRESIDENT
RACIST.
>> Juan: CHECKED THE AIRPORTS
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO SEE PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
LET'S ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
ONE LAST THING BEFORE WE GO --
>> Greg: THE HARMFUL EFFECT.
>> Juan: NO TERRORIST --
NO TERRORIST HAS EVER CROSSED
SEVEN BORDER.
>> Greg: YOU SOUND LIKE A RICH
CALIFORNIAN, JUAN.
>> Jedediah: ONE AND THREE
WOMEN GET SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Juan: HERE'S THE REAL
ISSUE.
POLITICO IS REPORTED THAT
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE WENT
TO THE PRESIDENT AND SAID LET'S
MAKE A DEAL TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEN LET'S TALK
ABOUT UPGRADING BORDER SECURITY.
DEMOCRATS SAID OKAY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID --
>> Jedediah: YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET THE BORDER
SECURITY.
HOW MANY RONALD REAGAN MISTAKES
DO YOU HAVE TO MAKE WHEN YOU GO
TO DEMOCRATS AND YOU SAY WE'LL
DO THIS.
OKAY, YOU CAVE IN THAT YOU NEVER
GET YOUR END OF THE DEAL.
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY.
>> Greg: THEY DON'T ACT LIKE
IT.
>> Dana: WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE
SHOW TO GET TO SO I'VE GOT TO
TEASE.